- Ah, this is ABC For Kids.
- [Both] ABC!
- Is this what I think it is, Art Attack.
- That's English.
- This is so good.
- I have so many failed art projects
because of this show.
- Was he involved in some kind of scandal
in the future, though?
- Oops. Weren't they all?
- I remember there were books, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah..
- And people that could
morph into animals.
As if that wasn't your go-to dream.
- I was really jealous of these guys.
Why can't I morph?
- When Tobias turned
into the eagle forever,
wouldn't have been jealous then.
- I liked the pictures in
the book when they were
halfway through the
transition, so they'd be
mostly human, but just
have like a weird nose.
- Oh Brum!
- Brum!
- If this is Brum, I am
honestly not watching.
- Mate, Brum was the bomb.
- Brum was like the seven
minutes you had to get through
so the rest of ABC Kids would start.
- Not true.
- Oh my God, The Ferals.
♫ Rattus the rat, Modigliana the cat
♫ They just love the fame and forune
♫ And they're never going back
♫ With Derryn the dog and that rabbit Mixy
♫ Running riot as the televise Feral TV ♫
- Yeah, not, it's:
♫ There's a rat, called Rattus
♫ He's the leader of the pack
♫ There's a cat called Modigliana ♫
- Oh, you were watching
a different one to me.
- Did they just give the finger?
- I always liked Modigliana the best.
She had flawless style.
Those like Madonna bras that she wore.
- Noddy was so cute, and those evil guys
were really scary, they
were always after Noddy.
- This is not a hetero-normative show.
- No.
- He slept in the same bed as Big Ears.
- Aw.
- They were very suspicious.
- Best show of all time.
- This was everything.
- I feel like this show
seriously prepared us kids
for like--
- For life!
- For life.
- Like, 100% the best show ever made.
They need to bring it back.
- How long as it on for?
- Well, it started in the late '80s...
- Yeah.
(sped up talking)
- It's great.
- The fox in the lemon tree.
That (beep) with my head!
- I think I was kind of
haunted by this show.
Like the one where the seagull poop,
everyone got pooped on by seagulls,
they were all just covered
in it, head to toe.
- Is this Gumby?
- What?
- [Both] Trapdoor!
- You're a fool if you dare!
- No, no, no-no, no.
- This was creepy.
It's like a chunk of snot with legs.
- Okay, this is really
iconic, but really weird.
- Mm-hm, so weird.
- He's just like a blob slave upstairs.
- BDSM.
- That's probably what it was.
- Yeah.
- What was in that trapdoor?
- I want to go home and
I want to watch them all.
- Round The Twist is on Netflix.
I'm going to re-watch it all.
- I can't believe you
haven't seen Round The Twist.
- I feel like I've missed out on a lot.
- You're getting these really quickly.
- Yeah, yeah.
I watched a lot of TV as a child.
- You did.
Didn't you go outside?
- No, why would I want to go
outside when I have this great,
these great shows to look forward to.